[Music]
you know what's over like officially
over slowly getting to know somebody
remember that like unpacking little
tidbits of someone's life over a series
of casual conversations that's done like
recently I met somebody at a party and
we talked for I don't know 20 20 minutes
all I got was their first name and her
last thing which used to be nothing but
nowadays it gets you everything even a
casual encounter by the shrimp plate on
a boozy Thursday evening if I get it if
I'm like Janice Palermo is that Janice
Palermo Oh gotcha
you're now completely Facebook able I
don't have to spend three weeks of a
lazy summer courting you and weaning
information and a charming and mildly
erotic way you're picturing it right
like a Monet painting blowing Danny Y&C
just like which Downton Abbey character
are you ooh
Lady Edith bold thanks to Facebook
that's the first thing I find out she's
Lady Edith
she took the quads Thanks plus I find
out where she went to high school the
names of everybody she knows photographs
of everybody she knows it's like I'm
gonna print out headshots and pin him to
a corkboard
like a cop trying to break up a drug
cartel Janice is the big cheese
she goes at the top with all the social
media is what I'm saying is like a huge
moving truck pulls up to your house
before you even go on your first date
some guys just like will you shine like
what it what is it everything this is
too much chin it's blue Bowl and don't
get me wrong sometimes all that
information it can be a time-saver I've
done that you scan their Facebook page
play a game I like to call spot the
deal-breakers you can do a real patches
like favorite movie is twister okay here
out here out last facebook status Sheryl
Crow is the truth I'm gonna sit this one
out
but no matter what it was simpler back
in the day I mean if you had someone's
first and last name the best you could
do - like investigate them was the phone
book but then some people just weren't
in the phone book that was the thing
then you were just left with strangers
going around like anybody yeah nobody no
Janet's Palermo Janice point sir do not
you ask
blammo Brad hand Janice brown medium
medium medium Janice Palermo you know
kind of a lady edith type photo that's
all I got you were screwed and then if
you did meet someone who knew her and
they gave you her phone number you'd
call Janice plentiful and then when she
answers you'd have to immediately
explain how you violated her privacy and
got her unlisted number
that was a tense moment she's like haha
hi Janice yeah sorry Roberts piece gave
me a number that is that is that is that
okay
would be an awkward pause just like you
feel like you got caught in the wing of
the house where the dinner party isn't
being thrown it's like who gave you the
number and what are you doing in the
master bedroom but it was better because
nowadays there's no build it goes from
zero information about a person to all
the information in one fell swoop so
we've stopped like falling in a rational
all-consuming random love we've moved to
just crunching data I've literally gone
online through every stage of a
relationship with a girl before we've
even gone out once it's true first I go
on Facebook for our first couple mine
dates you know what I mean she's not
aware of these but I'm like it's a first
day I see her hobbies interests favorite
bands that's stage one I'm starting to
like her stage two we start joking
around go on Twitter
see how witty her Barb's are and like a
forest is like a party for trees maybe
sage 3 got to meet the friends all of
her friends and not in real person in
real life you got to meet him on
Instagram you're just scrolling through
like oh they seem nice they like
drinking I like that uh-huh
thing then things get serious and you
meet the parents also on Instagram
you're like this is a big stuff there
they are
Oh mom and dad's still together dad's
got strong hands solid I like that mom
is hot good jeans okay weird sister
looks like drugs I can deal with that
[Music]
by that point up here we've already been
together a few months but then you start
clicking too far you get a little too
deep and you start cycling through some
old ex-boyfriends you know what I mean
I've actually caught myself being
jealous of somebody that I'm not even
dating in real life yet I start getting
to their vacation photos from 2008 I'm
like who's this guy put on a shirt I
just met this girl once and I'm already
like get your hands off Bob that's right
I called you Bob she's mine that makes
you the pump work myself into a tizzy
first message I ever send her is like I
don't think it's working out Janis I
mean I respect you as a person but we're
on two different paths and her first
message to me is sorry
[Applause]
[Music]